掌声欢迎 Anthropic 技术团队成员 Tariq Shihapar 上台。
大家好，我是 Tarek，在 Anthropic 做 Claude Code。开始之前，我们团队有个传统——演讲前先来张自拍。不介意的话跟我摆个姿势，我在 AI Engineer 现场拍一张。好，太棒了。那开始吧，正如预告，Fable 回来了。
今天晚些时候就会发布，具体时间请留意。我和 Kat Wu、Simon Wilson 会在十二点半有一场炉边对谈，到时候可能带来新消息。
Fable 是我特别兴奋的一个模型。它属于那种你一定会记住的 Anthropic 模型，就像 Sonnet 3.5 new、Opus 4、Opus 4.5。我对它有很深的感情和期待。要我形容 Fable，最贴切的说法是：地图正在展开。你在玩一款角色扮演游戏，之前一直在新手教程里。
而现在，你走到了开放世界的入口。有太多能做、能探索的东西。但也正因为能做的太多，会让人有点发怵、有点迷茫。所以这场分享，我想给大家一份 Fable 的实战指南：怎么跟这一类新模型打交道。
内容分四部分。本来打算写成系列文章，但一听说 Fable 要发布，我就想干脆在演讲里一次讲完，来个速通。四部分是：给 Claude 松绑、找到你的未知、接受阵痛、别太讲道理。先说第一个——给 Claude 松绑。
我们常说：模型是养出来的，不是设计出来的。我们不会一觉醒来说『要在 SweBench 上拿到 99%』。模型是精心培育出来的——喂它数据、反馈和算力。但归根结底这过程有点像有机生长，我们是在用的过程中一点点摸清它、跟它一起学习。
这也意味着，真正限制模型的其实是我们自己。我们套的框架、写提示词的方式，本质上都是我们对 Claude 理解程度的映射。我说的『松绑』意思是——
我们怎样更懂 Claude，才能释放它的能力？我们需要更深入理解 Fable。所以我的观点是：现在还非常早期，Fable 身上还有很多值得解锁的理解。
举个例子说说模型怎么变聪明，这事有点反直觉。几周前我看到一条爆火推特：为什么大模型答不出哪些宝可梦名字以 AW 结尾？一千只宝可梦里只有两只名字以 AW 结尾。
你问普通聊天模型，它答不出来，挺费解，因为它明明知道所有宝可梦名字。但你问 Claude Code 就能答对——它会把所有宝可梦抓下来，写个脚本筛出以 AW 结尾的。于是——
这就是我说的『给 Claude 松绑』。我们叫它能力悬置。Claude 变聪明的方式是尖峰式的——不是靠死记每只宝可梦再推理，而是你给它代码执行工具，它就能找出那两只以 AW 结尾的。所以 Fable 的挑战之一就是搞清这种能力悬置：现在有哪些新可能？这也是我很期待和大家一起探索的。
为了把这件事讲得更清楚，我想聊几个过去模型进步的例子。一个很大的例子当然是聊天模型。早期聊天模型需要你给它上下文，比如你可能把代码库粘进去。你可能会很自然地以为，解决编码问题的方法就是上下文窗口变得越来越大，最后我可以把整个代码库都粘进去，也许会有一亿 token 的上下文窗口。
但后来我们发现，真正有效的不是只给它更大的上下文，而是给它手脚。比如给它 bash 工具，给它和环境交互的方式，它就能自己构建和搜索上下文。这就是后来 Claude Code 背后的洞察之一。又是一次尖峰式的变化，是我们理解模型和使用模型方式上的一种新创新。
最近我们还推出了 Claude Tag。Claude Tag 被解锁的关键，是它可以主动工作，也可以多人协作。Claude Code 通常需要你提示它，它才开始干活。而 Claude 能够自己醒来、自己推进工作的能力，我们认为正在解锁下一波智能体。
但这里还有更多变化。比如最近我们删除了 Claude Code 系统提示词里的百分之八十。这就是模型需求会随时间变化的一个例子。最早在 Sonnet 3.5 new 那个阶段，系统提示词的最佳实践可能是：小系统提示词、少量工具、大量示例。
随着模型变聪明，你可以给它更多信息和更多指令，它也开始能遵守，于是系统提示词变得更大，里面有很多示例，也有很多工具。但最近我们发现，这一类新模型反而想要更少、更小的系统提示词。示例有时会限制它，因为它其实比我们给的示例更有想象力。
所以我们尝试给它上下文，而不只是给它约束。我们会尽量避免写“不要做这个”，虽然这对上一代模型非常必要。这就是系统提示词正在变化的方式，而且未来大概率还会继续变化。
另一个我非常喜欢的功能是 Ask User Question 工具。我刚加入 Claude Code 时就参与过这个功能。当 Claude 在规划，或者想问你问题时，它可以弹出一个多选对话框。对 Opus 4 来说，它几乎很难调用这个工具，我必须非常细致地调整工具，才能让它正常工作。后来到了 Opus 4.5，我就在想，如果我让它呢？
比如让它围绕一个规格文档问我四十个问题。它真的可以开始采访我。它提问的能力发生了跃迁。最近到了 Opus 4.8 和 Fable，我甚至可以让它构建一整份 HTML 报告，并把问题直接嵌在报告里。
这是一种和 Claude 互动的全新方式。所以 Claude 从你这里获取信息的方式，也一直在变化。说到这里，Markdown 和 HTML 也是我经常讨论的话题。最初，Markdown 对模型来说是不错的输出格式，可以呈现一点富文本信息。后来到了计划模式，它开始变成给你看的东西，你可以理解 Claude 接下来要做什么。
而现在，Claude 可以为你构建很深入的 HTML 报告。所以这又是一种模型以尖峰方式变聪明的例子。
我很喜欢强调，这更像生物学，而不是物理学。它仍然非常经验主义，非常有机。我们并不知道所有规则。但背后也确实有某种科学，有一种需要培养的直觉。所以我真的建议大家用这种方式对待 Fable。Anthropic 有一篇我很喜欢的论文，叫《大型语言模型的生物学》。
我们所有研究论文都尽量写给不同技术背景的人看，但这篇是我最喜欢的之一。如果你想进一步了解，我建议你去读一读。
前面我们讲了给 Claude 松绑。但当你和 Fable 一起工作时，你也需要给自己松绑。我经常思考的一件事是：地图不是领土。当我处理一个编码问题时，我脑子里的计划、提示词和规格说明，是地图。
但领土是真实的代码库、真实世界，以及 Claude 需要穿越的各种约束。每当 Claude 在领土里遇到地图上没有的东西，我就把它叫做一个未知。Claude 必须决定怎么处理它。那是一个我没有明确指定的决策点。
Fable 是我第一次强烈感到，我必须认真找出自己未知的模型之一。因为如果我不这么做，它会穿越很大的空间，遇到很多未知。所以问题是：你怎么找出自己的未知？Fable 的瓶颈，其实是我能不能把地图和领土对齐，找出那些未知。
这里有几种思考方式。我喜欢用一个矩阵。对于任何问题，我都有一堆“已知的已知”，这通常就是我写进提示词里的内容：我想要什么。然后我有“已知的未知”，也就是我知道自己还不知道，但还没弄清楚的东西。
接着是“未知的已知”，也就是那些太显然了、我根本不会写下来，但我一看到就知道对不对的东西。最后是“未知的未知”：我完全没考虑到什么？我不知道自己不知道什么？如果我知道了它，会不会改变我提示 Claude 的方式？幸运的是，你可以用 Claude，用 Fable，来帮你找这些未知。接下来我讲几个自己使用 Fable 的例子。
第一个，我喜欢做一种叫“盲点扫描”的事情。我会说：嘿，我正在接入一个我完全不了解的新认证服务。在这个代码库里，你能不能帮我做一次盲点扫描，找出和我相关的未知的未知，帮我把提示词写得更好？
这样 Claude 可能会去看认证模块，发现某个经常出现的麻烦死角。也许它会搜索我的 git diff 或 Slack。我可能会告诉它哪里有上下文，这样我就能了解所有坑点。
这个方法可以用得非常广。你可以用它学习一个新领域。我最近在做视频剪辑里的调色时就这么用过。我觉得它非常强大，而 Fable 在这件事上尤其厉害。从很多角度说，模型几乎对任何领域都比我知道得多，我要做的就是把这些知识从它那里引出来。
然后我喜欢用头脑风暴和原型来找出“未知的已知”。尤其在设计上，对我来说很多东西就是“看到才知道”。所以我可能会让它创建一个仪表盘，并告诉它我完全没有视觉品味，给我做一个 HTML 页面，里面有四个非常不同的设计方向，好让我做反应。
你可以根据需要继续调整，但核心想法是：帮助你发现那些无法用文字描述的东西。和模型一起工作，把这些东西找出来。
再往后是访谈。当我已经大概知道自己想做什么时，里面通常仍然有很多未知：我可能没有考虑到某些东西，也可能没有把它说清楚。所以我会让 Claude 采访我。我会给它更多上下文。对这类问题来说，补充一点关于你、你的工作、你所处阶段的上下文非常有帮助。比如告诉它：优先问那些会改变架构的问题。
然后是参考资料。给 Claude 一张地图的最好方式之一，就是给它另一张地图。也就是说，与其我自己把规格写出来，我可以直接说：这里有一段代码，代表我想实现的东西。
它可能来自另一个系统，或者另一种语言。但你可以让它读这段代码，理解它，然后以此开始工作。如果我在做一个 React 组件，我可能会给它一个 HTML mockup，把它作为地图传进去。我觉得这真的非常非常强大，而 Fable 在这件事上也非常厉害。还有一个我特别欣赏的做法是实现备注。
如果 Fable 在执行时遇到未知，就让它把这个未知记录下来。这样你能看到偏离发生在哪里，也能进一步理解为什么会这样。它通常会给你一些关于当时情况的上下文。
最后，我喜欢让 Fable 反过来考我，问我刚才发生了什么，确保我真的理解自己在做什么，也能在创建 PR 或合并时讲清楚这项工作。这是一个很好的方法，能确保你始终留在 Fable 的循环里。我认为这也是使用 Fable 最重要的部分之一：保持在循环中，确保你得到的是自己真正想要的结果。
这些就是我使用 Fable 的一些建议。我还想说，我第一次使用 Mythos 级别模型，也就是 Fable 时，既感到巨大的收获，也感到某种失落。我想稍微谈谈这件事。
当我回想没有大语言模型之前的编程，它感觉像一个异国他乡。我以前创办过一家 YC 公司，大概三十个人。那时候因为写代码太难，我们不断被迫做取舍。比如我们可以让应用更快，或者尝试原型化一个新功能。这个可能要一个月，那个可能要两个月，所以我们必须选择。那真的非常非常难。
几周前我回到那个代码库，想起一些自己当时想做的事情。
结果它们现在变得容易多了。以前可能要花几周的事情，现在几个小时就能做完。到某个时刻，你会觉得，怎么可能不笑呢？但说实话，又怎么可能不想哭呢？我真的非常非常热爱编程，热爱亲手写代码，热爱那种在脑子里看见整个代码库、把它转来转去的感觉。
但我也记得那些熬夜调试的夜晚，记得花几周做一个东西却跑不通。我记得自己像是在失败里游泳。我也记得我做过的大多数项目都失败了。大多数创业公司最后都会倒闭。总体来说，编程和写代码极其困难。尽管我享受那些高光时刻，但我已经回不去了。
我的反思是，唯一的出路就是穿过去。关于智能体式编程，还有很多东西要学；关于 Fable，也还有很多东西要学。但我相信，如果我们足够努力，始终留在循环里，给它松绑，我们就能走到那里。我们会从另一边出来，拥有多得多的东西。所以最后一部分，我想讲的就是“多得多”的那部分。我把它叫做：不那么讲道理。
Anthropic 里我最喜欢的一点，是我们相信取舍并不真实。我在以前的公司里非常习惯做一个“合理”的人。我会写下一串优先级，然后说，好吧，我们只能在这个和那个之间取舍。这说得通，所以这就是我们这个季度的优先级。但如果你全都做呢？
如果你逼现实世界来证明这个取舍真的存在呢？这是我非常珍视的 Anthropic 文化之一。往后看，我觉得自己会变得少一点“合理”。Claude 和 Fable 的数学改变了你思考取舍的方式。你脑子里有很多隐含的取舍，比如好、快、便宜。现在不是三选二，而是三个都要。
我认为，做更有野心的工作的最好方法，是重新框定问题，让我们自己也变得更有野心。因为证明智能体有效的唯一方式，就是以前所未有的速度，做出我们人生中最好的工作。
比如，这套幻灯片是我昨晚用 Fable 花大约四个小时做出来的。我很喜欢这套幻灯片，做的过程也很享受，而且速度非常快。我觉得如果你今天在 AI Engineer 现场，某种意义上，全世界都在看着你，等你证明 AI 是真的有用的。它不只是一个潮流，而是真的能让我们更有生产力，也能帮我们节省时间。
这就是我今年的目标：更有生产力，但少工作一点，多花时间和我真正关心的人在一起。同时也值得指出，构建东西变容易了，但创造价值仍然很难。作为 AI 工程师，我们有时会太关注构建过程和自己的工具配置。
但重点是创造价值。你需要尝试很多次，打很多次球，才能找到真正有价值的东西。但这才是目标。世界也正是在期待我们证明，AI 真的能够改变它。所以最后，我想说：去探索吧。把它变成现实。还有，少讲一点道理。谢谢。
就这样。